good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
happy Thursday it's almost the end of
the week and we're celebrating by having
one of my favorite people ever come on
the the toast you guys requested her I
heard your cries it's Hannah burner
Hannah burner how you D getting asked
back is like I mean my head is so big
right now you and Paige oh my God love
my life I was telling Paige you know I'm
like a nosy sorry for everyone who has
had to hear this twice but I'm like a
nosy [__] and I love having people on
during maternity leave people who have
podcast have big followings and seeing
like who really converts you know like
who's driving downloads who's who's
promoting the episode and bringing their
listeners you know great thing about
maternity Le is we're reaching new
audiences um and so I I'm a nosy curious
girl curious little cat and so I like to
see who performs well and the giggly
gires always show up for they come well
the G the gigglers and The Toasters I
feel like overlap a little literally
said the same thing Paige and I mean
we're in this weird place where like we
finished each other's sentences right
now we finish each other's sandwiches
sandwiches oh I'm hungry me too well not
you're not really
no had and I just had like a 10-minute
conversation about OIC before J no I'm I
miss being hungry sorry actually I'm
really not hungry saying saying you're
hungry is literally um for it's it's
like breathing for me like I just always
whenever it's like silent I'm like I'm
hungry do you feel like not to turn this
on you but you've like have to get a new
personality now okay I'm so glad you
brought that up and I think anybody
who's like been fat for a really
significant period of their life can
attest to how being fat is a personality
trait yeah and you have to act certain
ways and I just had this conversation
with Jackie where I was like I feel like
a lot of the things that I used to say
like I could get away with because when
you're fat like you're really invisible
like nobody gives you any sort of um
there's no Credence for you you never
have to worry about getting kidnapped
100% but I was like I just used to say
like kind of inappropriate things and
like I I feel like I can't say that
anymore cuz it's not appropriate whereas
like you used like I used to get away
with anything because people were never
really like putting respect on what you
said wow yeah I mean anything you say
comes with the context of who you are
that's why if someone says something
it's funny and someone says it and
they're like I'm offended no and also as
a comedian like my entire brand of humor
is about being fat being fat and the
self-deprecation that comes with that of
course and so it's kind of been and now
I really and I believe that like being
fat is a physical state of mind it's a
physical state but it's also a mental
state of mind so I have had to kind of
like I don't know what the [__] I'm
going to talk about like next but I was
talking to Paige about this that it's
actually the reason why I think OIC is
unfair cuz all the fat girls who had to
do the most do the most and created the
most incredible personalities are now
hot and funny and I'm feeling attacked
no by the way um that's why I feel like
the world can't handle this no I know I
I actually feel like a lot of the
backlash on OIC is from like skinny
people who've just really not had to try
like when you're they had skinny
privilege right you have to try so much
harder you have to be so funny you have
to be so exciting you have to do the
best makeup so now I have literally the
personality a 10 I have makeup skills 10
because I was always hiding like hair
Glam eyeliner and now people are
noticing me because when you're when
you're fat you're literally just
relegated to like I say it's over for
you ho it's over and by the way I
thought my whole life I'm like when I
get skinny I don't know when that's
going to be but when I get skinny it's
over for these hoes and the day has come
and I saw somebody on Tik Tok say this
and it was so appropriate because
everyone's been talking about the Roman
Empire they're like What's your Roman
Empire and somebody said this I was like
yes being skinny as somebody who was fat
for so long is my Roman Empire it's like
you think it's never going to happen and
I don't even know what to do now that
I'm here well that's what I want to ask
you because being skinny obviously
doesn't solve everything what are the
new issues that you're like turning to
cuz when you obsess about something I
find once you get it you just find a new
thing to obsess over well that's true
and as a mentally ill girl yes but
something I actually really struggle
with and I talked about this on our
patreon is like I now have a lot of
mixed feelings I have like shame I have
remorse I I feel like a lot of
embarrassment for the person I used to
be and who doesn't I know and I just
like find myself like getting angry at
myself for how I used to like not care
about my body and like my health mhm and
I I don't know how to reconcile that ooh
I know I but you know what it's so
self-aware of you are you flipping the
table I know sorry I'm B Walters the
morning no it's cuz in the morning I
can't talk so I'm like asking you
questions by the way I feel that and
something that you're doing that I find
myself doing all the time whenever I'm
on a podcast like well my sister Jackie
said and and Jackie told me this and me
and Jackie had this conversation you're
like well Paige and I were just say well
Paige I hung out with her two days ago
and we're talking about our week and I
was like so did you like mention me on
the toast of course and she was like
well obviously I'm like did you like say
I was your best friend and stuff so like
did she I don't remember I don't know I
don't think she used the phrase best
friend yeah I'm going to have to like
look back actually if I'm remembering
correctly I think she called you an
acquaintance that would be fitting
because right now she's in char charlest
so I don't know who she is when she's in
Charleston I don't know who she is 100%
I have no idea we talked about how
everyone's I'm just talking about P all
time but she goes to Charleston and we
were panicking we're like there's no
bodegas there's no like chicken parmesan
like what are you going to do so when
she's there I'm just like I'm here if
you need me right gold belly talk about
getting kidnapped literally every time
you come on this show on the show I feel
like you've done so much since the last
time you were here and I love no I feel
so like happy and excited for you like
you're post reality TV journey is just
unparalleled like I can't think of
anyone who's had more success off TV
cardi B yes she's my she's my everything
that's the perfect example and I just
feel like you're doing the most you're
killing it and I love it so what have
you been up to I feel like you're never
home you're always on the road yeah I'm
running away from my own thoughts I do
actually have an issue I love how we go
deep but I feel like we're very similar
like yesterday I I didn't have a gig
last night and I was watching the
Beckham documentary on Netflix highly
highly highly recommend um um but I
watch the whole thing like I watch six
hours and I was I don't know what to do
with myself when I don't have work no
you're like I'm a slob it's it's Zer to
100 like I'm either like people are like
you're an Olympian or people are like
you have the worst depression I've ever
seen no by the way that's like not to
complain because this like what we get
to do is so amazing no it's the only
thing I want to do but that's like kind
of a weird downside is like you have
weeks at a time where like you cannot
breathe and you can't see your family
and you're never home and then there's
like slow months and weeks and you feel
like a slab there's like a lot of
instability well Justin Bieber um said
that when he would great Justin Bieber
the amazing Justin Bieber my Roman
Empire said that he had so much dopamine
from performing Arenas as a kid that now
like average things just like can't him
don't excite him so the first time we
did a giggly Squad live show Paige my
besty um she literally calls me up like
two hours later in the hotel and she's
like I know how Justin Bieber felt and
I'm like calm down no but like she does
you are Justin Bieber we are right
wrting a lot of adrenaline highs we are
like addicts in a way where I was a
tennis player it was a lot of like big
wins bad losses so highs and lows so I'm
dealing with that like really crazy
exciting stuff but then like forgetting
how to be a normal human and I would
argue if I
wasn't people get drive from a lot of
different things I think I do get drive
from like failure like when bad things
happen to me or I fail like whatever
excites you like if I didn't have trauma
I would be just like a really peaceful
Pilates teacher loving life no but also
so I think because you went through a
period and I've been through like a few
of them where you totally had to rebuild
like can events you didn't know like
what you were going to be doing for a
living next like and I think some people
in this space just appear maybe it's not
that way but they appear to Coast like
things just like look easy for them they
don't have like big you know breakdowns
you know like they just seem to be like
always doing well and when you have to
completely rebuild your business and you
don't know like if you're going to be
able to do this full-time anymore it
gives you a sense of perspective to like
really appreciate apprciate the weeks
and months where you're peeking and
you're not always going to be peeking oh
for sure you don't know happiness until
you know like deep deep dark sadness so
true I also think I know that you
haven't had a lot of breakups in your
life cuz you're perfect um please but I
it's like breakups where if a girls had
a lot of breakups she always levels the
[__] up like a girl after a breakup I'm
like oh now you're a CEO you're like
running a marathon and you've done tons
of therapy so I see all these like
traumatic events that can happen that
you know sometimes it's your fault it's
their fault it's always a mix it's never
just you're the victim um there's you
can always be self-aware about things so
like I know that if I had nothing
happened to me over the last 5 years
like I would still be the 25-year-old
Hannah who's fine yeah but developed
she's undeveloped her brain's not
developed so I've definitely grown the
[__] up and once you grow up and and you
know you could survive shitty things
then you get dangerous then you're like
what world what do you want it's so true
and that's why I think I feel bonded to
you cuz we also are not walking around
feeling like we deserve this it's like
we know how difficult anytime anyone
even enjoys listening to us like I
literally am so grateful yeah and it
just I feel like um I I really do I
actually thinking about this morning I
feel like
uh every success or opportunity like I
feel like I earned you know it's not
like I blew up overnight and all these
like I feel like every person who listen
to the podcast like I worked so hard for
that one person yes you know the second
you think that like people deserve to
just listen to you is when you get
dangerous that's some dangerous [__]
well so we were just having this
conversation we do the toast every day
and you were like that's crazy but
you're at a place now where you
literally have like three or four weekly
podcasts so you pretty much every
weekday record a podcast and the one I
want to talk to you most about is your
most recent one because you did
something I've always wanted to do but
I've been absolutely petrified to do
which is start a podcast with your
husband because Ben is very frequently
on the show yeah and in the beginning
when he first started coming on oh my
god did I get sh because our stick and I
feel like your stick with your husband
is very similar and we do this on the
podcast but we also do this in bed like
we yell at each other like we're always
yelling at each other and it's like
there's a normal volume it's bickering
it's not we're not fighting about
infidelity is so [__] hot bickering
is my foreplay thank you for saying that
but I used to get so much i' be like
clutter you're so mean I'm like have you
ever been married [__] like and it used
to give me such anxiety and now we got
to a better place where like we're
figuring out and people love having been
on but to commit to doing it every week
is a brave thing Hannah it's a very
brave Choice well it was a transition
cuz burning in hell I was doing for 5
years and I was interviewing people and
now I'm on the road and I literally
don't have time so much admin and
research yes and if people don't know
Dez was on summer house for like
literally two days think about that last
night it became this whole thing and he
like didn't even tell his agent like he
shouldn't have gone but we were in that
early like we were we were talking on
the phone every night for like 6 hours
he was supposed to visit there were Co
issues like it was this insane like we
were not like living in reality so he
does it and I'm like it'll be great like
dead no literally like think about it
imagine your future husband is visiting
like how much better reality TV is that
than this guy that you're like newly
obsessed with and it obviously was not
my year or month or even my whatever and
I mean and he was so nice too like yeah
I don't feel like he did anything wrong
he literally like threw a pizza party
for people like like we did all these
things that you know people didn't say
but it's fine so he was like look I'm
not in this to get attention through you
you have your career I have my career
I'm not in this for publicity and I was
like okay hot love but then like we I I
almost felt guilt that it was my fault
brought into it was my fault that I I
brought him into it and subjected him to
that I wanted to protect him for a while
and also you don't want to get that high
with your relationship where you're
excited for the attent attention the
relationship's getting besides what it
actually is you're speaking absolute
[__] facts [__] gly like that's why
some people
are like you can tell do you love the
relationship or do you love the idea
that people have of your relationship
that like is obviously just made up
right like when people get upset about
celebrities breaking up I'm like you
have no idea who these people are like
he he could have been you know horrible
or she could have been so unhappy like
maybe this is a great thing yeah so it
was actually really healthy to not be
putting us in the public eye I actually
really understand that and I feel like I
I didn't I didn't know it at the time
but now looking back like you really
didn't do a lot of things publicly and
that's probably because you were like
traumatized from him coming on your show
and him like out of nowhere getting his
ass handed him for literally no reason
like literally no reason oh I understand
that a lot like feeling that guilt I had
so much guilt to the point that like God
forbid I posted a photo and like and
then people were like he's he's older
than me I'm 32 he's 47 zad and people
were like so mean agism but no one was
calling it out like that was straight
bullying and he just like stayed quiet
and he's so classy and he's such an
adult but I was like I'm sorry for
getting involved in my [__] dirty
mess for me to get attention that makes
so so like I had to sit with that work
on it and had to like not gain his trust
but like be in a safer place and like
also you needed to like let go of that
like remorse yes and he also he's a
comedian that's the hardest thing it's
not like I have some shy guy who no
social media he's in he's incredibly
like funny and smart and we have
obviously chemistry so we'd been like
kind of talking about a pod and he was
like if I can do what I love to do with
you which is Banter yeah then let's do
it so we like waited for the right
situation and he's been he basically
like produces it cuz Mom's working mom's
on the road of course so we did this
thing called burner phone um where
people can submit like voicemails
voicemails I love and we give have
different types of prompts so sometimes
it's really silly sometimes it's more
serious cuz I feel like I'm always
people have to listen to me all the time
and it's it's really fun to listen to
people be like wait there's real people
listening no that's like part of this
job I like didn't sign up for uh
listening I'm like no [__] I want to
talk what about me what about me but
you're right like it's really like in
order to be good at this line of work
it's half
listening
interview I we don't interview a lot of
people so like I never list no
interviewing is it's hard hard and
sometimes like they in a mood or like
they don't want to open up and you're
like I'm tired so it's at this point
where he me and him could just be
ourselves every now and then it's funny
cuz like he's is your husband so he'll
be like why'd you bring that up and I'm
like I don't know and do you ever um
like when me and Ben sometimes like
record patreon episodes at home like you
ever stop the recording and be like stop
saying that or like stop doing that no
well I'll like ask him something he's
like you know we're not talking about
that and I was like I thought it was
natural like I'm kidding or he'll be
like I have to pee and I'm like like you
have to pee we we're in the middle like
it is I'll send the like unedited clip
to Grace um who helps us edit and it's
so funny she's like I'm laughing so hard
at like the moments I have to cut I or
like a fly and he's like I have to
[__] kill this fly and I'm likez why
do we have to kill the fly right now
it's going to take 10 minutes no when
you're a professional podcaster it's
really hard to podcast with someone
who's new to the game like I can't and
that's also why I love having you and
page on and I said this to Jackie when I
FaceTime her after paig I was like it's
just so nice to podcast with a podcaster
and like say what you want podcast is a
skill it's not just sitting down and
talking there's a rhythm there's a
listen there's a talk making interesting
conversation a tangent like and you guys
are so good at that it's just so
refreshing now I really won't podcast
with anyone who's not like because it's
just it's too much work and the episodes
never really come out good well also
let's be honest it's a [__] hour
that's a long time I mean in our world
it goes by a second cuz we can chat
forever but it's not like just a quick
you know little interview on a red
carpet right which is fun too which is
very fun but it requires less uh
gymnastics yeah and you also have to
have chemistry with the person and
sometimes super famous people are the
worst interviews yeah and the best
interviews are not like question answer
question answer question answer it's
like question answer let's take a
tangent what about that tell me about
that like it's it's so much more than
that so um that's just really why I love
having you on I'm very grateful here and
The Toasters love you so what's better
than that no I'm so grateful we're going
deep I'm I love that I love cuz I feel
like you know me and you we could be
silly goofy laugh laugh laugh and we
will but I like to check in with you
emot yeah of course deep and something I
actually do talk no me neither and
something I think people are always
surprised by is like I'm really not
afraid to to like go deep I share a lot
not everything but like I think the most
interesting conversations are like when
people start crying if you don't start
crying don't tell me I'm actually ping
so bad right now me too are we cycled up
wait we might be and Taylor Sher has her
period too you know this like PMS
headaches like I woke up this morning
obviously haven't drank water in like 3
weeks would you like some of my L
there's lipstick all over it oh my God
it's okay thank you spicy water is not
my thing but what no it's like I feel
like seltzer water is like if water was
musical theater it's
like ha in your face jazz hands and I'm
like calm the [__] down I just need a
little bit of water oh my God if spicy
water didn't exist I love that you call
it spicy water I would probably be dead
because I've never drank water in my
life like I probably have five Salter
machines you know what when I moved into
my first labor when I M to my first
Department B I'm like let's get a soda
stream Israeli owned company support our
people yes and let me tell you it was
like the least convenient thing ever and
the bottle got really smelly and like it
was always spraying water all over the
counter I was like [__] this I don't
mean to disparage a little and maybe
maybe they've gotten better and maybe I
was doing it wrong but I like that you
could like make your own my mom and dad
have it and my dad like acts like he
made dinner when he presses the soda
stream and does he make like Diet Coke
and stuff you can make like soda yeah he
can he puts the little the Pod yeah the
little pod defeats the purpose it's
supposed to be for water like I would be
using my soda stream to make at home
Diet Coke just put apple juice in it
like and then you could put like uh
vodka and make like a nice carbonated
Vasa my God for sure but at the end of
the day everything tastes better when
someone else makes it that's so
beautifully sad and that's because I
can't cook me neither um so Hannah's
going to join me for the past five today
now before we do I think it's absolutely
important to remind everyone that
Jackie's book comes out on Monday and as
you can see if you're watching on
YouTube where my book used to be because
I'm such a supportive sister today I
have swiped it out and I probably will
keep it here for the next couple of
weeks for Jackie's book it's called the
camper and the counselor it's a
children's book it's written by a
toaster but you don't have to be a
toaster to enjoy it perfect for kids of
any age boy girl you know they're going
to Camp they uh are going to be homesick
or even not it's just a story about a
girl who faces a challenge mhm and what
did she do with that challenge why you
look at me when you said that stop she
Rises to the occasion yes and camping is
so like did you go to Camp so I was a
weird tennis girl so I where did you
grow up again I grew up in Brooklyn New
York but I would go to like tennis camps
all the time but I had all my friends
who went to like regular Camp regular
Camp um so when we were in I forget what
great I was but uh we all went to a fat
camp no I read about this journey in my
book if you want to read it and I think
uh maybe year one we had went for our
sister Olivia who had like really
struggled with her weight when she was
young and um we were supporting her we
were supporting that's the type of
family we were like we were one sister
was doing something we were leaving the
camp that we love Jonas Brothers yes
when I tell you we ended up loving fat
camp and we went every summer till I was
like 18 it was the best like so many of
my best friends are from fat camp but I
think in the beginning um like Olivia
was a little embarrassed so we told
people we went to tennis camp and let me
tell you how half the girls at this Camp
were just like Japs from Long Island and
they also they told everyone oh I'm
going to Sports Camp I'm going to tennis
camp what by the way so be honest tennis
camp is fat camp let me ask you
something because I I feel like I spoke
about tennis camp so much as a young
child you want know if what the [__] is
tennis camp like what do you do dud
tennis camp is crazy so there's like all
these levels and you get put into levels
like the top Court the medium Court the
weaker Court there was only one level at
Fat Cam and it was fat but then there
was also so because like when I went I
wasn't struggling with my weight at the
time what's that like um so I just went
to like be supportive so I got this
bracelet it was called maintenance and
oh you're an ally that meant I wasn't on
the program like I could do whatever I
wanted I didn't have to like eat like I
could just live and like that bracelet
made you next level honestly it sounds
so traumatic no it was really hard like
like I would steal someone else's
bracelets so just so I could have a hot
dog I know but like if you showed up
with a bracelet and like you didn't look
like you were bracelet worthy like it
wasn't something you could really fake
you know what I mean
wait these are like this [__] up no I
know I read about it in my book a lot
how like it was the best Summers of my
life like for real like to be so relaxed
and like not give a [__] people there
those are like kids who like hide all
year long like they're so ashamed and to
be at a place where it really was like
amazing but I do think a lot of my food
issues were're being sub are from being
subjected to like that sort of well
there's a thin line between like
promoting eating disorders and like
being so obsessed with it yeah and by
the way I I actually feel like it was it
it was really a regular Camp you don't
realize that camp how active if you are
oh my god well I was say tennis camp you
wake up you eat and then you play 3
hours of tennis lunch 2 hours of tennis
and then you like go to bed right so
like fat camp was literal camp like you
had activities every day but your first
activity was like a Zumba or like
something really really active and then
it was just like swim Lake lunch were
were there weigh-ins yes every Sunday oh
my God yeah so it wasn't just how you
feel on the inside no you're not paying
you know x amount of money for a summer
to feel I know I know that I was jealous
of all my friends who had that like Camp
life cuz they'd be like oh she's my Camp
friend and you could just tell that they
were family and you're like but like we
sit in Algebra 2 together and she's like
no I know we from camp Camp friends were
Elite like the way you loved your Camp
friends and it was just because absence
makes the heart grow fond you only saw
them for two months and maybe like one
weekend out the year Camp friendships
like I can't wait to send my kids
memories are just like insane bonded for
life I can't wait to send my kids to
Camp cuz I can sleep yeah no no and go
to
Europe but like the price of Camp these
days like is insane IV League school no
literally it's like a semester at school
I did you study abroad no I was playing
tennis in University so tox I didn't
even have like a life I didn't have a
life I also didn't have um like holidays
like we for Thanksgiving I'd be like at
a holiday in with like a a sad guy on
the piano eating like a buffet cuz like
the tennis tournaments were always when
like the big ones were when everyone had
a break oh my God but um do you hate
pickle
ball you inspire ired me so hard with
your pick ball rant cuz you said it was
their PR is great I don't love that I'm
kind of jealous like I feel like I've
been a tennis gir for so long I
appreciate you acknowledging I'm jealous
and I feel like people are like this is
the best racket sport I know that tennis
aesthetically the girlies love yeah and
I do acknowledge that tennis is very
difficult oh my God the running the
court is doesn't need to be that big the
court does not need to be that big but
the fact that they're like taking tennis
courts and and changing their pickle
ball is like hard for me so I spoke
about that on uh the toast I just so out
of the 45,000 tennis courts in US and
Canada 30% of them have been converted
to pick a ball courts and real house
Real Housewife of Miami star Julia's
wife Martina naala she's you know her
wait Martina Nava's wife is on Miami I
want to make sure I'm say yeah Martina
blonde yeah older she's cancer now very
sadly she's one of the greatest players
that ever lived her wife is Miami you
don't know that I didn't how well I
don't I can't watch you and Martina is
on The Housewives all the time shut the
f up okay so you want to hear about
their life they have this like really
turn Farm in Fort Lauderdale where they
spend a lot of their time but when
they're filming Farm means you've made
it yeah but they have this like sick
like new modern Miami house that's where
like they film and stuff um and it's
they have kind of have like a a crazy
marriage
like like it's really crazy well now
it's like I almost want to watch cuz my
tennis nerd and me wants to see what my
team they went to the Miami open there
was like a whole thing oh we should go
to the Miami open by the way 100% also
with pick a ball it doesn't have to be
that loud it's like soain character
energy no like a lot of communities are
like forming tennis you put it in a
bubble during the winter and if there's
people playing pickleball the bubbles
just
like it sounds like a play tennis and be
like next door and you really wouldn't
hear the ball popping like the popping
with the woofle ball for pickle ball is
really driving people Nothing the ding
the doning in these small communities
like it's becoming an issue small noise
pollution it is noise pollution is real
I mean as New Yorkers honestly we
probably enjoy the noise like I don't
want to be quiet and listen to my own
thoughts I also I forgot to address if
you're watching on YouTube I am wearing
a shirt that I feel like looks like a
labia and I feel like I walked in you
looked at it and I was like she thought
that I was wearing a labia shirt I did
look at it cuz I just clocked you I
wanted to know what you were wearing now
I wasn't thinking anything yeah um but
now that you've pointed out it does have
labik Tendencies but I feel like it's
feminist it has flaps yeah like clap
your labia yeah no it's definitely
giving vaginal it's giving reproduction
like it's it's giving female parts
there's a lot going on you look
beautiful oh my God you look beautiful
we look beautiful thank you and we're
going to deliver the past five so Hannah
I have one last question for you mhm are
you ready to deliver the past five
stories that you need to know I'm so
excited yes today's episode of the toast
is brought to you by my king over at
State Farm the State Farm personal price
plan helps you create a plan that gives
you options so you are just getting an
affordable price and it comes with a lot
of benefits like the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and most importantly an
affordable price just for you so after
all isn't life just better when you can
personalize things think about it like
this what are your music playlist
podcast feeds social media Scrolls all
have in common well they're a reflection
of you so we all know my social media is
full of like this Tik Tok drama that I
can't even get into right now it's so
layered and we know Jackie is more of a
reals girl so even we're so similar but
we're still we require such
personalization s such customization and
what's more personal than Insurance
that's what the State Farm personal
price plan is all about it's giving you
options to help you personalize your
coverage so that you can protect what
you care about most all at an affordable
price just for you so you can see more
of yourself in everything that you love
so think about Jackie and I we're so
similar but even our insurance needs are
so different I'm a renter in New York
she's a homeowner in Florida she is a
tesler she has kids like so many
different things that are so personal
and your plan should reflect you
whatever you're looking for from an
insurance provider and that's where
State Farm has you covered so like a
good neighbor State Farm is there I'm
sorry like a good neighbor State Farm is
there call or go to statefarm.com today
to create your State Farm personal price
plan price vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary again call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan prices vary by
state options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
today's episode is also brought to you
by the farmer dog the farmer dog makes
and delivers fresh healthy dog food it's
developed by vets it's nutritionally
balanced and it's made from real healthy
ingredients to human food safety
standards it is the best option for dogs
at all stages of life because it's not
kibble it's not anything canned it's
just real healthy food so when you think
about traditional dry and wet dog food
they're really high processed they can
use much lower quality ingredients than
they claim to and they're really
difficult to portion accurately but
that's why the farmer's dog is elevating
things you go online you tell them all
about your dog they'll ask you a ton of
questions about its weight Its Behavior
things like that and then you're going
to start getting fresh healthy dog food
delivered to your home pre-portioned and
there's so many benefits for your dog I
feel like what you put in your dog's
body can really affect its longevity its
quality of life so for Theo I noticed he
had so much more energy his breath oh my
God was so much better he was making
like more consistent poops and they were
just more normal sizes like so many he
just became so much more regular and he
had a lot of energy and I just felt like
it was such a good decision investing in
fresh healthy dog food for Theo and it's
not just fresh higher quality food they
also send the food pre-portioned
specifically for your dog based on their
unique nutritional needs so it makes it
easy to help maintain your dog's weight
which is one of the biggest indicators
of a full healthy life if your Str spro
is the most important thing in your life
which he should be check out the
farmer's dog and get 50% off your first
box of fresh healthy food at
thefarmersdog.com toast plus you're
getting free shipping so just go to
thefarmersdog.com toast that's
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 50% off
your first box plus free shipping okay
now we have like a little bit of like a
lesbian update questionable lesbian I
don't know what the [__] going on and
the more I see about Kyla Mauricio like
the weirder it is I saw the weirdest
Instagram reals from Dancing With the
Stars where they like interviewed
Mauricio post dance and they're like
what's going on with
and he's like you know we're going
through a tough time like it was so
weird yeah and now yesterday Kyle
Richards was spotted picking up Morgan
Wade from the airport after confirming
that she is separated from Mauricio
yansy so Kyle was waiting for Morgan
Wade at the LAX International Airport on
Wednesday after the country singer left
the terminal Kyle picked her up in a
Black Range Rover the Virginia based
songwriter approached the car um in
matching pants and colorful sneakers she
kept a low profile in sunglasses and
Kyle was sported wearing black
sunglasses behind the wheel literally
picking her up from the airport which is
something I wouldn't even do for my
husband I was about to say like call
Uber call an Uber there's really like
there's no reason to ask someone to pick
you up from the airport unless you live
in Kansas City have you performed in
Kansas City yes don't you love that
[__] airport uh all of them look the
same to me okay well then you would
remember the Kansas City one it's 3 ft
long there's literally one Starbucks and
you step off the plane you probably take
six steps to your Uber or actually they
don't even have Uber it's like a taxi
it's incredible like I'm not into these
Metropolis airports where you need to
take a shuttle a bus and a train to get
to your game an air what even is an air
TR [__] air TRS except except if there
wasn't the air train like there isn't at
JFK I'd have to walk the JFK airports
you get the B terminal anything past
like b28 I mean even Loria they change
your gate and it's like it has to say 17
minutes to let you know you're going to
miss your flight no it's absurd the
amount you have to walk so you know what
I'm actually grateful for an air TR I've
done like a run of I've done a run
there's nothing more humiliating let me
ask you like a question do you place
categories no okay feel like that's a
camp thing it's not it's like I don't
know we play with our family and like
there's this running J it's a happy
family thing people say that like I
cheated and it bothers me so much okay I
feel like I maybe told the story on the
chose once before so basically you get a
letter and then you get a list of
categories and you have to find a
category with uh you have to name
something in that category that starts
with that letter before the timer runs
out and so you can get really creative
but it's really not fair because you you
could just throw an adjective I'm an
adjective in front of anything so if
it's like things you find at the beach
and I remember Olivia had wrote um
muscular people it's like no you find
people at the beach the muscular is
Superfluous but it was for the M right
so we didn't give her the we didn't give
her the point and for me um with the
adjective like it has to be really
necessary like it has to make sense so
things you find at an airport we got the
letter H and I wrote hurried people cuz
you always see people running cuz it
isn't just people it is always H but
there are also hurried people my family
came after me so [__] hard I didn't
get the point and literally to this day
maybe this was 10 years ago that point
would have changed my life it bothers me
so much because conceptually like based
on the premises of the worldes I'm a Ral
follower like my adjective was necessary
it made it corre cu the beach is not
always muscular people right but there
is without a doubt always a person in a
hurry so whenever you're at the airport
and you see someone hurrying you just go
the [__] I think of hurried people I
think of hurried people guys if you're
like a psycho with categories rules let
me know should gotten the point love
that it is socially acceptable though to
like be just run in the airport where
like New York City I'll I run like I'll
you like jog or like rush like if I'm
running late to something which is like
I always get dropped off at the wrong
Uber or I'm always running late I will
run through people running for my life
and I know people are looking at me but
I'm like I
don't it's really embarrassing and then
how come I could run on the treadmill
for 10 minutes but like running for 30
seconds in New York I'm out of breath
wow Flex you can run on the treadmill
for 10 minutes I mean I could do the
walk thing yeah I could I I recently
started going to the gym so I was really
surprised to learn like how out of shape
that that I was and I do the treadmill
um I've gotten up where I can run to a
full song which I'm like really proud of
cuz I couldn't even get through a chorus
it's a lot of it is mental what I would
do this is pretty toxic but like when I
was training you have to trick yourself
that like you're literally getting
chased by a lion and get to that next
level of adrenaline I think it would be
more productive for me to like imagine a
Crispy Cream in front of me you know if
you were hungry like I'm not afraid of a
lion honestly like put me out of my
misery like just enough and like if it's
beautiful Safari desert like you know
what oh gorgeous way to go if this is
how I go this is how I go like I'm
contributing to the uh food prism what's
it called food paraman food chain food
chain you go and she's juicy um I just
have to say about Morgan Wade yeah I
like how we went categories why is every
single country singer's name Morgan Wade
Morgan wall and Morgan Wade yeah no
that's a fair point that's a fair point
also but you're so right cuz I see
things so like when people are seen
they've chose to be seen I don't care if
you have sunglasses on and you look all
like oh I don't want how did TMZ know
that Morgan Wade who outside of her
relationship with Kyle Richards is a
relatively unknown country artist like
how do they know where she was going to
be and when also yeah I'm not going to
pick you up unless like there was a
serious problem also cuz I know my
driver's license I'm coming to pick you
up if I know the paparazzi there like if
Ben's like oh I'm coming up I'm going to
the airport I heard Tam is going to be
there like I'm showing up in my prom
dress I want to know I guess is Dancing
with the Stars under NBC ABC so
different so it's a huge move that
they're letting Bravo celebrities now go
on that and and Mauricio also has a
reality show on Netflix so they're kind
of like everywhere cuz there was a point
where Bravo was like hardcore you can't
do anything outside of Bravo ever they
didn't they don't even let you talk
about like stuff on podcast and now like
they let Vanderpump people talk about it
Ariana's also on uh on is on it so
there's this I didn't even asking him
about like a storyline that's wild
Behavior but I guess there's see good
for the show they should have been doing
that all along it's globalization it's
globalization do you think Kyle Richards
is in a Rel relationship with Morgan
Wade
[Music]
um I like haven't really thought about
it really oh my God it's all I think
about like as in I do I think like
psychics are right most of the time yeah
that was some crazy [__] like that
psychic came for her throat your husband
she wasn't even a psychic okay she was
she was just a Woman They found on the
street she was like a mentally ill woman
living in Beverly Hills who love to vape
she was like she just was a huge fan of
the show your husband will never
emotionally fulfill you and then I was
like emotional fulfillment from men is
like a difficult thing how many women
were like yeah no [__] we know but at
the time when that show was airing there
was like a lot of rumors about Marcio
cheating on Kyle yes so like the timing
and all the women were like o yes spooky
I mean I I think it's like commit or
don't I don't know what this like middle
thing is like and why they're not
telling us anything like I feel like
bronwin is pissed bronwin like this was
my story line This is organic like
bronwin was so staged like when bronwin
was like married but also dating a woman
and then like she also I think then
abused her husband they called like
there was like a whole [__] thing she
didn't do like the launch correctly this
is this is exciting I'm not going to lie
like I'm talking about it milking it is
what these celebrities are doing I mean
she this is her job you know she's doing
a pretty good job and I know that Kyle
has not t been the one who has like the
main story line for a while so it's her
time it's her time true actually she
also has not been in the hot seat really
ever since season 1 when like her family
[__] went down and you know she really
did bleed out like the show is what it
is because of you stole my goddamn house
like and that was really dark [__] for
Kyle's family with Kim's sobriety so she
bled out like the first two seasons and
then she said I'm done with you [__]
like it's your turn now but now we're on
like season 14 it's time girl yeah the
merry go round is coming back it's your
turn it's your turn I'm invested cuz
there's such a fascinating family they
they are they are yeah I guess I'll have
to say I think they're also not telling
us anything because it is on the show
yes and the trailer just dropped and it
comes out in 2 weeks so like hopefully
we'll get some clarification on what the
[__] is going on because this roll out
has been so weird like we're divorced no
we're not silenc we're wearing our like
you're not just friends with like a hot
young country singer no you're a
housewife no in California yeah what do
you talk about I have no [__] idea
that's a great point now our Second
Story is a continuation of a story we've
been talking about for weeks the Drew
Barry more of it all oh so drewberry
more I'm not going to bore everyone but
remember she was one of the people who
was going to bring her show back despite
the writer strike being over um because
she wanted to you know get everyone back
to work but then I I don't have a
publicist which was like a very brave
thing for her to do and then she
backtracked two seconds later and then 5
seconds later the strike was over so had
she just waited I literally texted my
friend I was like how mad is Dre right
now yeah now it's getting worse because
her head writers are refusing to return
to her show even though the strike is
over and her show was like big pretty
popping it's it's not easy for a daytime
talk show to do well by Phillips had one
remember Chris Jenner oh my God I
blocked that out remember Bethany
remember um Tyra yeah but hers was
successful yeah um so the Drew Barrymore
show is set to return in less than two
weeks without three very important
people a trio of Drew Barrymore's
co-head writers have reportedly decided
to walk away from the gig following the
actress's controversial decisions amid
the Writers Guild of America strike
according to the Hollywood Reporter
producers are scrambling to find new
writers after white Christina Keenan and
Liz Co all quit their jobs after the
monthong protest ended Tuesday they
basically were like you said you don't
need us then fine all three women have
worked on the show since its first
season and were very vocal during the
straight they even picketed outside of
the NYC office of CBS on multiple
occasions with signs that read honk if
you love union labors and Drew's news
strikes so um I have to say I don't
think this will affect the show I mean
so many writers have been out of work
now for months I can't imagine that
they're not going to find three people
who want to work on a successful show
like I but it kind of is like this is
really tainting Drew's
image yeah which I don't like I actually
do understand why she came back I don't
think it was an assault on the writers I
think there are so many people who work
for her show who are not in a union who
had to take odd jobs who had been out of
work for months and that was for these
people that's what Bill Mt said he's
like I'm returning without the writers
the show will not be as funny but I I
need like other people who work on the
show who aren't in the union to work
like so I understood why but I didn't
understand doing it and then
backtracking cuz it was such a Brave
thing to do like you have to have really
thought it through knowing you're going
to get backlash but then stick with it
yes so to get backlash and then
backtrack makes you look like and then
post like a 7 minute rambly kind of like
I could have a public get a publicist
figure out how you want to say it
succinctly so we don't have to listen to
an eight minute weird video I have to
imagine Drew Barrymore at the level that
she is had a strategy no it looked
strategy yes and maybe that was the
strategy to kind be like I'm so organic
whatever and like crying and stuff that
ain't a strategy that's a [__] show it
it is hard in this industry cuz I feel
like when you fly close to the Sun all
like Taylor Swift right now which is
making me nervous and nervy she was
doing so well like there's actually a
quote in the Beckham documentary last
night sorry oh my God I'm about to quote
the John meany special okay there's a
quote that says like the higher you are
on the mountain the more wind so it's
like you have to be able to handle the
power that comes with the responsibility
of power I don't know that was a
Spider-Man quote John M said like is a
prison oh well that the oo that is so
powerful cuz yeah think about like the
Chrissy tan stuff it's the same thing
where like people feel really lied to
when it's like you're supposed to be
everyone's best friend and you don't
care about some people so you get even
worse backlash than like Bill Mah no one
thought he was nice so true bill Mah
we're like I could see him you know like
not that he's a bad guy but like no one
was like he's my bestie no and he's not
like a front-facing person who wants
everybody to feel love he does like hot
takes on a show yeah he's controversial
polarized
yes um but John meany had said it
because you know before his divorce he
was like America sweetheart like I don't
think there was a comic more beloved
less he wasn't he's not even
controversial as a comedian everybody
loved him and what did he do he got
divorced which isn't a crime but people
felt felt so invested in his marriage
because he's just like this America
sweetheart nice guy very likable you
would have thought the way people
reacted like the drama around it like he
was a serial killer well because he
would joke about his wife and their
marriage in like such a fun nice way
that people were like you lied to us and
he brought people in yes which was a
mistake and this goes back to the
beginning of our conversation where I
said context matters like when Bill Mar
says it everyone's like okay and then
when she says it people are like oh hell
[__] no because Bill Mah has got made
a career off of like making people
uncomfortable and making people think
and not just being you know like a
person who says what everybody else is
saying he's controversial and goes
against the grain and he makes you think
whereas like Drew Barrymore is just kind
of like a Hollywood Elite who does
everything right and you know what not
to play dou Advocate but like Drew I
have so much empathy for her and all
like the horrible things she's gone
through in the industry that's why I'm
always like don't trigger her I know she
has like an inner child who like hasn't
fully been healed yes and I feel like
she she loves the show so much um but
the way filled by it honestly call a
publicist cuz like don't put people
through that kind of like up and down
stuff like make a decision decide stick
with it or don't yeah and publicists
aren't like I mean whenever I've dealt
with a publicist they always just tell
me to shut up they always just like
ignore it talking just ignore it cuz
like a lot of the time you can't control
narratives you make it worse so having a
publicist is just basically telling the
person like this is the the best way to
avoid people getting hurt and drama and
stuff like that but um those three
girlies they must have really been vocal
to be like don't you dare right cuz
they've been out of work for a while and
now like their main source of income is
back and they don't even want it like
that's crazy it's wild Behavior I can't
wait to Google them after this like
where are they now she'll get writers
like writers are dying to work like
they've been out of work for many many
months so I'm not worried about it but
this is just like three of your top
writers is the voice of the show so it
might like true just giving writers
credit no it's true it could change the
tone yeah that's very true I mean you
think about like the Chelsea Lately show
which I think was the greatest talk show
ever I actually never watched it oh my
God like it was when I was like that was
my Roman Empire how old are you um sorry
to ask okay 30 and 25 months oh my God
we're the same age wait in 25 months how
old are you
32 oh 30 and 25 months I thought you
said 30 in 25 months I'm like you're
younger than
me I joke that I'm like a baby like you
give months you're like I'm 2472 months
yeah cuz nobody has the time to do the
math all right well I'm 29 but I don't
know I felt like I was like a little
young to be watching it did you not feel
that way um I would like 10:00 be going
to sleep I did feel a little young cuz
it was all these like older Comics but I
felt like I was like being naughty
watching like the adults gossip at night
after like two beers you know when your
parents start talking and you're like
okay you dirty little dogs literally
like but no I never watch that's like
Heather McDonald now when I see her I
have this like memory of her on the
table I know she's so legendary like she
is one of the writers on white chicks
like I did you know that I actually did
not know that cuz I know that she's in
it and when I was on her podcast a
little while ago I'm like like the
craziest thing like you were in white
chick she's like I literally wrote it
with other people like yes no she's been
in the a long time she's been very very
kind to me to and especially as two
girls who were like gone to standup
after her she could be Cy like she could
have been like oh now you want to stand
up it's so true she could totally be
rude she's one of the nicest people I've
ever met she could been rud to me I
would have said thank you yeah no I
texted her this morning and the first
time I ever met her like I it was so
refreshing to meet someone who was
actually so [__] funny in person in
addition to like the podcast and
everything I really like her I have a
lot of respect for her she's also very
open to the Goss Like the gossip yeah we
just went to dinner uh when she came to
New York York and I was like Jackie you
have to come that's amazing and we just
like talk [__] I just like I I want to
know her thoughts on so many things and
people you know yes and she was very
open to hearing like my stuff too where
like I can tell when people don't want
to hear things like they're like I have
my narrative I don't want to hear I
don't gossip she's a girly she's a
girl's girl I like her we support um so
wishing drew the best I do feel bad that
like nobody really talked about how when
she announced her show coming back like
a bunch of other smaller talk shows did
too like Jennifer Hudson nobody she got
everybody's [__] on her face like nobody
was came for got come for even remotely
she yeah her she there was poop on her
yeah like she got it all and I also
think that like people are treating her
like she is the the people who won't pay
the work I know like right let's let's
put our anger in the right place like
she's a sag member she was doing what
she thought was best for like people who
worked for her like everybody's just
trying their best like I disagree with
what she did but I also I do think I
understand likeability is a burden
prison it's also a burden like yes like
the David Beckham documentary um no he
was so loved and then he made like one
little mistake with like that alleged
Affair he actually did something on the
soccer field where like he messed up a
little but it wasn't even his fault and
everyone just blamed it on him or were
like he was the hero and the same thing
that can make you be the hero can make
you be the villain type of idea you
either die the hero or live long enough
to become the villain Shea Sheena
marishe Sheena marishe who I just saw
two days ago where um I did her pod how
was how was Shea mishe doing well I'm a
fan like I'm a fan from the Beginning by
the way so am I like I had the worst
breakup of my life and I would just turn
on V pump rules and watch Sheena cry
about a guy and I would be like we the
same we're the same or like you just
feel less bad about yourself and that's
what she does for the world and she's
really like I have to say say what you
want about her she has always been
herself always been herself she never
changed for those girls who were so
[__] mean to her like she withstood
all of that and you know what she's like
one of the ogs on the show now she's one
of she was demoted before and still
showed up every day like that's like
someone who's just like I'm going to
work hard and also when I was going
through difficult times she would she
was showing up to my standup shows I
have to say she did not have to it's so
important to remember people who were
kind to you during like your career uh
like I will never in my life have a bad
word to say about Jonathan jabon he
could not have been kinder to me when I
got canceled sending me text messages
like they made me feel so much better
like it's just the little things people
do and then you also notice like who
distan themselves and also who's nice to
you when start popping that's why was
Shea I keep an Excel spreadsheet in my
mind of people who are only nice to me
so do I have a Rolodex like literally
people from high school I was like
nervous like I one Vander pump was
popping off even though like Shea was my
girl I was like I don't want to start
hitting her up more even though like
people were asking me for the gossip but
I was like I want her to know that I
don't like like her more now that she
has like she's popping and seeing her I
was just like are you good but it's just
great to see like she was vlogging for
so long no one cared she was podcasting
for so long people made fun of her and
now her [__] is hot and it's like she
didn't get get lucky it's true she
waited it out she worked hard she's a
hard worker and true she's kind of just
like she's a girls girl and she shows
you who she is that's actually really
true like I don't feel like she would
actually deceive me in any way she not
like a bad person yeah okay we have some
absolutely heartbreaking news oh no I
Carly Revival has been cancelled after
three seasons on Paramount plus it's
time to say goodbye I didn't know there
was a Paramount Plus you didn't Kidd oh
I was like where do you watch drag
race no it's really not one of the
popular ones it's they really shouldn't
be canceling a show that I actually had
heard like people were watching you know
and also like when the [__] is
Yellowstone coming back we don't know so
you really need your content yeah so
after three seasons the Revival of the
Beloved Nickelodeon Series has come to
an end I Carly will not be returning for
a fourth season on par Mount plus the
series had a great three season run
delivered what fans really wanted to see
with kly and Freddy finally getting
together we want to thank the entire
cast writers directors and producers
along with the whole car and Freddy
[__] and and we're done we're done and
see you next year orgasm done
um I didn't feel like this was a Revival
we particularly needed yeah I didn't
watch but I was like a big gu Carly
Queen growing up so like I was
supportive I I'm not a big fan of
revivals yeah I mean how I met your
father yeah I heard was good was cute I
think right so I think there's ways to
do it like I think like reunions and
Revival are such like loow hanging fruit
like for Hollywood like do something new
yeah but sometimes they stop like I
actually think the way they did the
Friends reunion was very good it was
like a live televised event it wasn't
everybody acting again you know it
doesn't need to always be the that yes I
also think the way they did Fuller house
was cute where like the younger C the
kids are now the adults and they have
like a whole new cast I want revivals of
old school reality TV shows yes we need
room Raiders back we need next we need
next which was brutal no next we can
never survive in this climate like next
was the most vapid [__] the people
who signed up for next were that's like
going on next is self harm next to like
literally if I steep stepped off the bus
and I had one foot on the bus one foot
on the pavement and somebody said next
like seriously that would be the end for
me like that would be my 13th reason I
would not [__] be okay that would be
worse than both our reality experiences
combined horrible like I thought I had a
bed when I went on says to the Dress no
next next where I need a next I don't
need a next rehab I need a next where
are they now I need a next rehab yeah no
like next here's how next true life
here's how next ruined my life do you
remember um the one where the parents
hated the boyfriend or girlfriend are
you talking about true life no you're
talking about next it was a dating show
it's a different one and the parents
hate the boyfriend and the boyfriend's
always like you know like smoking weed
or something like we hate him she
deserves better and the girl's like 15
yeah and then they set her up on a
couple days dates and they have to sit
on the couch with the boyfriend and the
parents watching how I con how I con do
you remember the show Bridal plasty yes
where like 10 Brides to be competed on a
reality show where each episode had like
a different Bridal themed Challenge and
the winner get this the winner would get
the plastic surgery of their choosing
for their wedding so after she won the
challenge she would come back with like
a bandage on her nose or her like Jaw
reset her boobs done and she would
recover in the Mansion while the the
girls went on to the next activity like
she would get to sit the week out
because she got her surgery which is so
insane to me cuz a man literally said I
love you for you and everything about
you and she goes perfect let me change
myself Bridal plusy was the craziest
[__] I'd ever seen in life was after the
swan right yes did you ever watch um I
actually think it's still on it's one of
my favorites Four Weddings no let me
tell you about Four
Weddings it's on TLC okay well TLC is
fire it's TLC is another planet so they
take four Brides They all meet each
other and they're all having their
weddings each bride goes to the other's
wedding so in total they all go to Four
Weddings and the Whoever has the best
wedding gets a $110,000 honeymoon do
they try to [__] each other's weddings
up so you have to rate the wedding based
on dress food like Decor um beon like a
whole category of things but um they can
try sabotage it you can't they have like
a system where uh in order to stop
somebody from like bombing somebody
else's wedding like if some girl clearly
had the best wedding I for the system
they system they the L score whatever um
let me tell you it's [__] absolute
[__] [__] complaining I mean her
dress was pretty but it was a little too
bedazzled oh my God the steak is cold
I'm starving wear's some mashed potatoes
the band was not good there was no food
at cocktail hour it's literally just
Naggy [__] complaining for 45 [__]
minutes let's be honest that's what
everyone's doing at the wedding they're
just doing it subtly under their and
they like just complain about the venue
and the pastor and like the noises from
outside
it's Cutthroat I would love one of the
brides to end up just like falling in
love with like the pastor or the groups
but the thing is so then they all get
together with the husbands at a mansion
to find out who wins at the end yes and
they're like fake cheersing one another
they're like dying to know who's won
it's never who you'd
expect it's a crazy [__] show I'm
always talking about Four Weddings I
mean reality TV back in the day was not
real not or too real a little too it's
actually true because now it's like so
scripted and like not scripted but like
manipulated because nowadays people get
real Fame from it like and you have so
much to lose so much to lose and so much
to gain where back then it was like yeah
people saw you once on the next bus and
like go off I mean the facts they would
say for the next thing like were those
writers that made it up def in post
definitely because they would be like
once took his guinea pig to
like his butt yeah yeah like once lived
with a guinea pig up its ass like it's
crazy out of pocket [__] and then you'd
be like yeah I could see that for him
that was one of the best shows like ever
created ever created I'm just surprised
why they're not revamping it cuz they're
revamping all the '90s and the Y2K stuff
I want it next can't can't exist in this
culture like for real room Raiders my
Cannon event was when they would go in
the people's rooms and they take out the
light to see and there would just be
like the black light and there' be just
seen like everywhere like on the lamp
like on the ceiling and it every episode
pit my
ride exhibit pit my ride they'd be like
yeah know I'm really into
um
Candy back of your car candy bar like
insane like Willy Wonka lives in the car
it was not real those cars were
definitely not Road safe like no that
was some other [__] that was oh my God I
like not even close to G driver's
license would watch it and be like and
then when the music would play the heart
the whole car would Shake um and yeah
there was definitely no way that the
weight would work when they were like we
have a horse in the back of it cuz you
said once you likees you like horses
it's kind of like your mom actually Remy
Bader made a joke that like her mom she
once went to like one Jesse McCartney
concert and then like 10 years later she
got her Jesse McCartney like one thing
you liked for one second to be polite
your whole room is covered in Jesse
McCartney but a lot of those makeover
shows which I thought was fascinating
you know those like
over home edition yes I was I used to
watch as a family are you talking about
the tax situation oh my God so people
would get these houses and they'd have
like no income and then they'd have to
upkeep these houses with like taxes and
like air conditioning and hot tubs and
pools no it put people into Financial
ruin and no one talks about it no and
these were like parents whose kids had
cancer and that's why they were getting
the free house and then they were
literally put intoy More Money More
Problems and then Ty who like you know I
don't know him personally Pennington
with his crazy spiky hair crazy spiky
hair like he looks like a boy band
member that like defunct yeah that was
in the microwave for too long and he was
like I've saved all your lives then
bounces and no one follows up not even
an email complete Financial ruin today's
episode is brought to you by Loft and it
couldn't come at a better time because
it just feels like for fall maybe All
Seasons but fall specifically like when
we're transitioning our wardrobe it
shouldn't be that hard to find things to
wear and loft is the go-to destination
for everything you need in your wardrobe
this season so be sure to check them out
they have new Rivals drop all the time
they have fun pants Silhouettes they
have flirty tops midi skirts sweater
dresses fun outerwear that's all just
perfect for fall they touch on all
seasons and they have always have like
the most relevant trends at you know at
Loft but most importantly they're always
offered at a great price because like
having to keep up with the trends is not
something that's sustainable but Loft
has got you covered they always have
reasonable pricing they always have
really really cute things whether you're
looking for stuff for work where you
want to be like a cute corporate girly
you're dating you want to be a cute
dating girly whatever girly area you're
in Loft has you covered so for outerwear
they have the biggest selection of
outerwear yet you're not going to want
to miss out on these modern Staples and
on Trend Silhouettes think about where
fashion Meats function they want to make
the world aware that they're a vibrant
destination for winter coats jackets
Blazers Blazers are so having a moment
right now here we're belting our Blazers
I don't know they're back and better
than ever with a fall collection of fun
feminine fashion they have a modern mix
of all day anyday pieces that offer
endless versatility so let's keep
showing up for ourselves and each other
by wearing what love as a thank you for
listening from now through January 1st
2024 use code toast loft.com to receive
$25 off your full price purchase
exclusion Supply see podcast description
for terms that's today through January
1st 2024 use code toast at loft.com for
$20 off your full price purchase today's
episode is also brought to you by Dipsy
picture this you're hanging out in your
favorite spot headphones on and the
world around you Fades away when you're
listening to one of the Dipsy stories
you're getting immersed in a vivid world
where every touch breath and stolen
glance is felt with breathtaking
intensity so this is for my smut girlies
if you're a spicy book girly listen up
Dipsy is going to be the platform for
you it is an app full of hundreds of
short sexy audio stories that are
designed by women and for women they
bring scenarios to life with immersive
soundscapes realistic characters you can
discover stories about Second Chance
romances adventurous vacation flings hot
and heavy hookups whatever like your
your Trope is enemies to lovers like you
can find anything at dipy there's a
growing library of fantasy series with
vampires Greek gods fairy smut to
explore the bounds of your pleasure new
content is released every week so in
between listening to your favorite
stories again and again you can always
find something new to explore they also
have soothing sleep stories they have
Wellness sessions and actually written
stories if you want to read instead of
listen so let Dipsy be your go-to place
to spice up your me time explore your
fantasies relax and unwind or even heat
things up with a partner so for
listeners of the show Dipsy is offering
an extended 30-day free trial when you
go to dipy stories.com toast that's 30
days of full access for free when you go
to d p s e a stories.com
toast Dipsy stories.com toast if you're
a like a spicy book girly a smuck girly
or an audiobook girly really recommend
Dipsy it's really fun it's just great to
have on your phone wherever you are
vacation honeymoon spicing up on your
honeymoon go to Dipsy stories.com
toast people want talk about I think
that's probably the same thing with Pimp
My Ride definitely like the value of the
car just went up so did your monthly
payments they get arrested immediately
they're like you can't have fire torch
in the back of your car none of this is
up to code you're done hand over the KE
you can't even fit in a parking spot all
that to say I Carly you will be
missed our next story so this is a TV
show I never watch uhuh um but and this
is a spoiler alert if you watch The
Masked Singer okay do you know who got
revealed as the M as someone got
eliminated didn't win shockingly and
spoiler alert turn it off if you watch
singer in un see last night's episode we
have the identity has been uncovered it
is Vander pump rules villain Tom sandal
I'm going to say a controversial
take I feel empathy for Raquel that she
is the only one that hasn't monetized
from the tra that's not a hot take I
think that's a completely Fair AR
deserves it yep Tom does not does not at
least give give or Kel a cut I
completely agree I think she's so busy
focusing on her mental health like I
Jackie and I had said this towards the
end of the reunions and stuff and just
like all the The Fallout afterwards it
in in our opinion like went completely
too far like when they were pretty much
telling Rael to go kill herself like it
was really actually not okay um and it
seemed like yeah she did something wrong
yes let's keep in mind she didn't murder
anyone nope she made a really really
really big mistake and she deserved for
her friends to be angry with her but to
have like millions of people telling you
to kill your yourself in addition to
like your actual friends in addition to
your friends I wish that okay maybe how
take I would like to see Raquel still on
the show I don't think she should be
fired I think people deserve I don't
think she was fired I think her her
family told her like she couldn't do it
she can't like no I I mean if anyone I
understand I mean I wasn't I didn't have
to deal with that extent but I do think
that like it's all stories and there
eventually is Redemption for everyone um
and also like who knows Ariana could
[__] up next season and then is she the
devil suddenly and then is Raquel
redeemed yeah like it's just that's
that's these shows and everyone forgets
immediately and next thing you know
people might be hating on Ariana cuz
she's doing so well and it's like she
didn't choose like ability is a prison
like well so that's why I'm a little
nervous to her I'm nervous about I'm
nervous I'm just nervous Nelly no I feel
that 100% and I do actually have like a
lot of sympathy for Raquel I have
sympathy for Raquel but I also have
sympathy for Ariana a little where I
wouldn't be surprised if this season
some people start turning on her for
like jealous
opportunities like everyone on the show
has been through things I feel like I
heard Stacey talk about this on maybe La
La's podcast where it was like we've all
been cheated on you know Jackson Kristen
and Stacey season one like that's the
same exact thing as Raquel Tom and there
wasn't this like the show was smaller
obviously and it was like less
surprising because like Jacks and
Kristen were both insane um but they've
all kind of bled out like I mean and
Randall like everybody's had like this
big thing and there hasn't been this
like wave of global love adoration money
opportunities so I could definitely see
people getting like annoyed yeah and if
she messes up even slightly people are
waiting I think yep yep yep um and that
is women in the Arts it's so true but
Tom sandal uh is continuing uh his you
know uh journey of thinking people want
to hear him play music and he went on
the mask singer and he did not win
surprisingly he uh I think it's the
second week like he literally just got
out I do have to say that nothing bonds
Vander pump rules more than the love for
music it's so true between DJ James
Kennedy K talk man you're a bad man and
then what was that song laa and James
wrote together where she's like singing
on the floor and she's like yeah yeah
like obsessed as someone who's been on
reality show not one person actually no
Kyle did put out a I think he put out a
rap song Once who sorry I wasn't
listening I was really s oh no Kyle Kyle
Cook put out a rap song Once no people
don't talk about it um I mean enough
Bravo
music what is your favorite let's be for
real Lan yeah well good as gold will
always be great it's actually a really
good song Luan has some like actually
sh of course Money Can't bu class but
not of enough people talk about Simon
van Camp's iconic song I am real I am
real it literally like wasn't a song
He's is he singing or rapping singing
well he wore red leather pants and he's
sang it on watch drens live as someone
who has put out absolute bangers
yourself do are there any Banger is
coming up did you enjoy the process of
making a banger should I try to make a
banger you should I actually found the
process to be incredibly stressful yeah
um I love like I love the fact that I
have two songs like I'm not seriously
pursuing a music career I love my songs
I'm obsessed with my songs would you
rather go on tour for standup or like
six songs okay so whenever I'm like
about to go on stage I always think like
imagine if all these people were here
just to hear me like sing a song like
imag if like I had like a full roster of
music and like you were buying tickets
to hear me and and the same amount of
tickets were being sold to see me that's
like for me that's my dream like I have
the best job in the world I love doing
standup but I'm always like if I was
here to like be a pop star like this
would be so much more fun so comedians
are famously very jealous of pop stars
because I come up with an hour of
material tore it for me to come back to
your city I have to come up with a new
hour of material that's 50 plus jokes so
you can there are people who have done
two hit song one hit songs and can do a
whole career based on that one two and a
half minute song y so like we're so
jealous we are but I think as a standup
it's a much more intellectually
stimulating job than like I think for a
lot of people singing the same songs
over and over and over again for 25
years like is it's actually miserable
mhm yes like Madonna's like if I sing
like a virgin one more time like I mean
think about selion with the residency
for so many years same [__] 15 songs
like it's a lot wow but also when I
listen to music I listen to the same
song 400 times but then it's like eating
a certain food like you get hyper
fixation and then you're over it you
could never eat it again done well um
Tom sandal released a statement oh he's
saying I ain't worried by One Direction
it's actually um an amazing song choice
and he said making my debut as the
driver last week oh yeah so he got
eliminated on the second week was so
rewarding it felt so great to get all
the love from the panel and the audience
something as you know I haven't gotten
much of lately as a kid I always wanted
to be famous I model I modeled I acted
and of course I saying I was always
waiting to become a household name I
just didn't know it would be everyone
hating me but I'm here to show the world
that I'm more than my mistakes being
here already feels like a healing
experience getting to share my talent
instead of my drama is exactly what I
needed so tonight I'm going to keep my
eye on the ball because I'm not ready to
take off this mask this is the thing
he's also on Special Forces no he's
making money right now and he has a
dumbass podcast that no one listen to do
have to say when you're going through a
hard time you could like sit in it or
you can just keep moving keep working
and like I do respect that he's not
giving up on life and like at no time do
I ever want anyone to be like life is
not worth living because of the hate
that they're getting so I have empathy
in that way but I do think um he should
stop I agree is that what you were going
to
say you
basically well like you could take a
second to like reflect a little but I do
want to say the vitriol I like that word
love the vit all that that man has
gotten I hope that you girls give the
same energy to men who have cheated on
you and don't take them back cuz I feel
like a lot of people are like [__] that
dude and then their boyfriend's just
like the same after day do you remember
that phrase that everybody in like
Middle School used to say I am Rubber
and you are glue what bounces off of me
sticks to you I feel like that's
literally Tom sandal I don't know why I
feel like nothing penetrates him I think
it's because he's like an actual like
diagnosed narcissist and so all this
attention albeit negative it's attention
you know it's not debilitating him would
AAL neurotypical person he definitely
enjoys that everyone knows who he is
which is sick yeah cuz I remember like a
feeling of I hope my name's not in the
news today cuz you're just you're just
like please no one say my name um and I
like like earned attention like I don't
even like the attention of like oh I saw
you on the show I want someone to be
like oh I love your pod like that
something like you worked and put out
earned there not just like oh I saw your
face once somewhere yep but he's it's
giving like a like women just when you
hurt a woman and then you do well it's
it like makes us all a little upset of
course no and Raquel is over here like
fighting for her life no I know and
what's his deal with Raquel right now
he's still playing along with it like we
might be we might not be no she's like
I'm done he's crazy um and he's like I
wish her well okay whenever a guy says I
wish her well like that's bad he wants
to kill her and and also like he hurt
her yeah of course he heard why are you
wishing me well why are you wishing me
well you should not um our fifth and
final story last night Selena Gomez had
held an event for her rare impact fun
where she's like uh her rare Beauty like
charity they do a lot of mental health
work and people were really surprised to
see her Kidney donor Franc Risa show up
on the red carpet and she did an
interview she says the ups and downs in
her Selena gome friendship had nothing
to do with the kidney and like sorry I'm
just not buying it Francy reisa is
sharing some insight kidney is a main
character no I know sharing some insight
in to the kidney let me hear the kidneys
no and by the way Francy Risa went on
Ben's podcast and spoke very openly
she's like there's no beef with me and
Selena but then she's saying there's ups
and downs here right and
like her and Selena like went through
like a year where they didn't talk so
question mark I don't know how that
drama made it to the public like how
they didn't keep that on the law no
because Francia um was like was leaving
comments so somebody had posted that uh
Selena Gomez did an interview where she
said her only friend in the industry is
Taylor Swift and frany re I saw it and
was like wow has been in London for the
last 3 years and I'm out here giving you
organs whenever you need vital organs
vital orans and so she was pissed wom in
stem and then um Selena actually
responded to that comment and was like I
wasn't like talking about you like they
were like beefing so we all knew and
then then they're both like it's all
good so we're like but what did we just
say like don't ass light us yeah so
here's what she said sometimes I feel
like people need to spend time apart in
order to grow we had to almost go on our
own Journeys to grow I needed to to take
some time for myself and figure out what
the hell was going on with me because I
was not okay I went through a lot in my
childhood and I will be talking about it
very soon Selena has been such a huge
important supporter of
that I'm not buying it I'm really
not it s that was a good publicist that
was a good publicist it feels like maybe
Francia was like Rogue for a little
while yes she was Rogue and now it's
back now it's being real in I mean
Selena's dealing with a lot of friend
drama in the public what else remind me
hails oh yeah well they were like never
friends yeah but apparently they were
seing at of dinner together they weren't
oh it was the same restaurant at the
same restaurant like similar timing but
completely opposite sides of the
restaurant like never approached never
collided no I got I fell into that
rabbit hole too like not me believing
everything I see on the internet I need
to become a little bit more of like a
critical thinker and like a more um
nuanced consumer an educated yeah like I
I know better than to fall for that but
here I am also like these I images like
it's really like it's [__] me up like
I see these crazy things I'm like oh my
God no way was Taylor Swift spotted out
with Kanye like but it's literally AI
it's just for clickbait I know and it's
working because I'm clicking how are you
feeling about I have to bring up Travis
Kelsey and um are you
getting over stimulated by it I am
actually I didn't even choose a story
about it today I notic um and I want to
protect Taylor because like you said
she's at that level where you get spoken
about so much there's only one way to go
so I'm doing my and not speaking about
her I love that for you supporting her I
also feel like the Kardashians are so
mad right now I know cuz there was like
a year where they were that like when
every single day was when it like Kim
and Pete and like there was just a lot
going on um that was them and they they
haven't been that for a while and now
tailor it and it must be tough and
especially with all the hype with the
eras tour like every celebrity flying to
every single show and then the six shows
in LA and like I'm sure one of their
kids loves Taylor no it's Taylor's world
and we're living it yeah and that must
be hard do you think that she did she
sell out the movie on um it I don't I
don't know if I'm sure it has sold out
it's about to hit like a AMC record it's
going to be like the highest scoring
movie like ever made because people were
like oh it's like good promo right now
yeah also is it true sorry just want my
last two seconds about because you know
everything about her did she say no to
the Super Bowl so I just had this
conversation with another co-host for
many many years Taylor was a Diet Coke
Ambassador and it was the diet Pepsi I
mean it was the Pepsi halftime show so
she was not allowed to do it because
there was a and for many years I believe
that noncompete exed and she was allowed
to do it then most recently Apple music
uh became a sponsor and she was
immediately eligible um and the erist
Tor conflicted with it and I'm I don't
know if they approached her formally but
she has not done it yet I'm sure they've
asked she will do it I'm sure cuz it's
her like one thing that she has done is
it crazy to say like I think she's too
big for it I love that so much like like
people were saying that they think she's
is going to be the headliner at
Coachella because like her schedule had
a break for the weeks of Coachella I
like I literally think she's too big for
Coachella also these these football
teams been like hey you're invited
anytime to our game I'm like your $400
ticket thirsty to her to see a game that
she doesn't care about everyone's being
everyone's showing their true colors
yeah are Cuban thirsty sorry don't just
throw her [__] around like that her
golden [__] on her puss respect on her
[__] 100% it's it it's annoying me cuz
also she's like helping men which is
like inevitable it's inevitable when
you're making so much money that some
men will benefit from it so true so true
like our husbands literally that's
literally we are the tailor Swifts of
the podcast Mama's working Mama's
working go away get me a song give me
soda give me die Coke which is so
relatable of her I know I loved her die
Coke era and it was also like when her
album read was coming out so like
everything was red d red and it was just
like she was like this I'll never forget
the commercial her like sitting
backstage like writing a song listening
to diet I mean drinking diet coke like
obsess I do have to say though I think
the diet coke girlies are not okay not
like people don't talk about it I have a
crazy thing to say I'm actually like
more of a Diet Pepsi girly like my house
I'm a Pepsi house but of course I
anytime I go to a restaurant I'm like
I'll have a DI what happened to you as a
kid that made that happen it was a
recent transition oh I'll actually I'll
tell you a little bit about it first of
all like I always knew in my soul like I
actually liked the taste of Diet Pepsi
better but like branding wise I was like
Diet Coke diet coke diet coke diet coke
and then right before I got like big can
in 2018 I had locked down this enormous
deal with Diet Coke it was like the
probably the biggest like most
accomplishing thing I was ever going to
do and of course I got cancelled and all
my brand deals fired me and which was
understandable I like wasn't mad Diet
Coke was like we're out I'm like oh of
course um but then they released like
thank you but then they released a
statement that like made the news cycle
pick up my cancellation again it like
started a whole other onslaught of drama
and I was like and I'm like Diet Coke
causes diabetes all the time I was like
you really actually I don't know if
that's true I'm just you didn't have to
go that hard rum you didn't there was
absolutely no reason for you to release
that statement it is it is sad I hadn't
posted any content yet like the
partnership hadn't even a gun so they
could have just can it literally tastes
no one needed to know it tastes like
bitter bitter bitter
herbs and then I was like you know what
[__] dieet Coke and now I can actually
live in my truth Diet Pepsi Diet Pepsi
caffeine free like you [__] are
sleeping on it and everybody gives me so
so much [__] like it's like it feels
good for me to know that you're dumb and
I'm smart you know I I do think cuz I
have people in my life who would drink
like eight die Cokes a day and they're
like there's no sugar there's no
calories and I'm like then what's in it
aspartame heroin heroin and I'm also in
my oepic journey I'm I'm like I'm down
to one soda a day wow and usually like a
treat I'm wild though like this is
actually like so much weirder I I like
Dr Pepper that's not weird at all d d I
think it's underrated do D Dr Pepper or
Dr Pepper either or Diet doct pepper is
literal like heaven it's socking good
yeah yeah I think diet Dr Pepper doesn't
I think Justin gini he's the they made
him small when I realized a few years
ago that the man in the Dr Pepper
commercials who sings just the sweet
ones was Justin guini of from Justin to
Kelly Fame I that for me like that was a
Canon event that was your Roman Empire
nobody could interfere like I was shook
shook talk about a Rebrand um Hannah if
anybody wants to follow you tell them
where they can do that and tell them
about all your podcasts and your
upcoming standard shows yeah listen to
burner phone with me and Dez and of
course giggly Squad which is my pride
and joy my baby um follow me on Tik Tok
we're Tik tocking we are Tik toing we're
always Tik toing I'm so proud of you
thank you oh I forgot to update everyone
we finally made a toast Tik Tok finally
I know I was like hoarding that because
I wanted it for mine I well what I do is
the giggly Squad when it's like my
favorite ones I'll put it on mine but
otherwise all of them go on the giggly
Squad good to know good to know and you
could I think yeah you figure it out so
it's the toast pod so make sure to
follow us there because good for you
thank you cuz you guys have the best
Clips thank you um also I do have a tour
I'm trying to sell tickets in Handover
Marland I don't really know where it is
Maryland gires show up and show out show
up show out um I just announced Reno
Madison Milwaukee I love Milwaukee a lot
of places yeah Milwaukee's very fun
going on tour actually like really makes
you appreciate how much like how many
better cities there are than New York
they're cleaner they're safer they're
more efficiently run they're very like
new and modern their trains work yeah as
a new people from New York you know
we're all like New York is the best were
so great I didn't realize there were
other cities I was like this is fully a
city no Milwaukee is absolutely gorgeous
this time of year it's gorgeous and they
have all these old towns and beers I
love Charlotte oh so many great towns so
cute I I love a vintage shop that I find
cuz vintage shops here it's like $300
for a sweater with mites and bed bugs
and then you go to like Milwaukee and
it's like $10 for Prada yeah also
there's this comedian Ryan Hamilton who
has this great joke he's like people say
New Yorkers are like if you can make it
here you can make it anywhere and he's
like see if a New Yorker can make it
somewhere else that's impressive no by
the way it's so true like P when no
foods like available at 11:00 p.m. we're
like what how do people live no how do
people live though like serious us they
just go to sleep like a normal person
maybe they're on
OIC actually oic's everywhere it should
be it's literally the best most
life-changing drug I'm obsessed with it
sponsor um Hannah thank you so much for
being here oh my God thank you so much
just went by too fast it really did an
hour and 12 minutes we're so verbose
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so Spotify public
radio radi cast box all the places
listen to podcast find us to five starw
about a beautiful stunning and wickedly
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing day and we'll see you tomorrow
bye
yes